madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce lundi 26 juillet
les alertes à la pollution se
multiplient en france après les
bouches-du-rhône et le calvados eux sont
bordeaux et aix en provence qui
connaissent aujourd'hui une pollution à
l'ozone le beau temps et l'absence de
vent sont bien sûr les principaux
responsables philippe douste-blazy
propose la création d'une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire sur la pollution
il sera notre invité dans ce journal au
lendemain des obsèques du roi hassan ii
le maroc passe doucement dans l'air de
mohamed 6 mai les défis que le jeune roi
s'apprête à relever sont immenses entre
analphabétisme et chômage patronat
gouvernement et syndicats s'accordent
sur les préretraites dans l'automobile
35 mille salariés sont concernés dans
vingt-trois mille chez peugeot et
renault
et puis nous irons à avignon le festival
a reçu la visite de jane birkin hier
soir avec des arrangements musicaux
originaux pour les chansons de serge
gainsbourg
la situation reste très préoccupante sur
le front des incendies partout en corse
et dans tout le sud-est de la france les
secours restent mobilisés au total 5000
pompiers 26 ans 26 avions bombardiers
d'eau qui s'apprête à intervenir si le
vent venait à relancer les feux dans le
lot un début d'incendié a même été
maîtrisé mais c'est en italie que la
situation est la plus difficile dans la
région de savone des incendies
continuent de faire des ravages d'eric
uretères tout autour du bassin
méditerranéen le même constat la pinette
desséché s'enflamment au moindre
prétexte en italie dans l'arrière-pays
de gênes les départs de feu se
multiplient depuis plusieurs jours et ce
matin la situation s'est aggravée dans
la région de savone le feu avancé sur un
front de quatre à cinq kilomètres
deux canadair et un hélicoptère sont
mobilisés l'origine du sinistre
et suspecte
suspect aussi le gigantesque incendie du
sud de la france
il a ravagé 1500 hectares de forêt
méditerranéenne depuis trois jours à
saint rémy de provence
les gendarmes mènent l'enquêté suspect
également les nombreux départs de feux
constater encore ce week end là 110 les
alpilles à peine maîtriser trois
sinistres s'allume simultanément au nord
de l'île
le vent la nature décès chez les
températures élevées
là non plus il explique pas tout ce
week-end dans le massif des alpilles
2000 hectares de garrigue et de pinèdes
de son parti en fumée même chose en
corse avec mille hectares détruits dans
la région de ghisonaccia et à chaque
fois la suspicion d'avoir affaire à des
pyromanes en corse
les enquêtes ont déjà commencé olivier
théron et frédéric besson ont suivi une
équipe de gendarmes près de solaro
autant chercher un mégot dans un
cendrier géant
les gendarmes arpente le lit du feu à la
recherche d'un indice des restes de ce
qui aurait pu être un engin incendiaire
samedi les flammes ont ravagé plus de
100 hectares à solaro les pompiers
avaient le tournis le peu prenez partout
en même temps dans le maquis et les
zones habitées une évidence
l'incendié criminel et je suis un peu
quand même
il y aurait deux simultanément à la
partie sud
de la commune quand on avait quasiment
l'excusé la famille en alu deux autres
et deux en territoire
ça a commencé ici sur une route peu
fréquentée en bordure des habitations
j'étais donc jamais elle peut travailler
là bas
ai je lu de voitures et de suite après
j'ai vu les laver les voitures parties
je passais attention je pense que
j'avais à peine son parti j'ai vu les
plans les gendarmes en enquête de
flagrant délit vont faire le tour des
rives des voisins de l'incendié ils
essaient de recouper les témoignages de
mise à feu ici dans le var il ya une
unique mise à feu une unique les
arrivées avant le chemin qui parle de
lame à être il faut absolument que la
population nous aide soient vigilantes
également à tout moment surtout pendant
les périodes de grand vent qui sont des
périodes propices pour départs de feu de
feu et à l'agissement des des criminels
appeler au civisme établir un
signalement regarder le fichier des
pyromanes saisir des indices ne suffit
pas à trouver le coupable surtout s'il
n'y a pas de mobile apparent en corse
depuis le début de l'année il y a eu 5
150 départs de feu et une seule
arrestation et je vous le disais la
situation reste très préoccupante dans
tout le sud est c'est ainsi que du côté
de carpentras on a noté une dizaine de
départs de feu aujourd'hui d'autres
incendies ont dû être maîtrisé près de
corte
il faut dire que dans certains endroits
il n'a pas plu depuis le 23 avril pour
intervenir le plus rapidement possible
les pompiers multiplient les
entraînements comme ces commandos
pompiers de l'armée qui sont basés à
solenzara en corse reportage d'alain du
bas et de france vaillant
fonctionnant au ralenti encore nous
sommes à bord d'un hélicoptère puma de
la base aérienne 126 à solenzara
en dessous le maquis corse et sécrète à
l'intérieur des commandos pompe ils
appartiennent à l'armée de l'air ils
sont à l'entraînement
leur rôle en intervient toujours sur les
crêtes particulièrement difficile
l'enfance est en train de régulièrement
à cette mission d'où cette fonction de
commandos d'où cette fonction de
commandos héliportés pompiers 1 parce
que vous avez les commandos au plus les
commandos contre ces deux choses
différentes pour attaquer les flots de
critiques mais commando qui agissent en
deux vagues et pionnier composé de six
hommes
ils ont la charge d'établir une zone
d'atterrissage ou d'ouvrir un chemin
d'accès pour des moyens motorisés des
commandos d'attac si j'aime aussi leur
mission est très particulière lutter au
coeur du brasier
les qualités requises pour un commando
pompiers je dirais ya quatre qualité
d'abord dieu condition physique ça c'est
très indispensable après rigueur
discipline et professionnalisme pour ses
commandes au conflit l'eau arrive par
les airs cette bâche contient 1200
litres
elle peut alimenter de lens autonomie
l'hélicoptère fait en permanence des
navettes pour les remplir mais pour les
pilotes
l'opération est risquée on attend
revient souvent dans les conditions de
météo très dégradée par des vents très
forts et tout ça fait que vont les
difficultés sont quand même assez
importante dans chaque mission
ces commandos fonds qui sont peu connus
et pourtant depuis 20 ans ici encore il
freine énormément de risques pour lutter
contre les feux de l'été le moyen et 10
complémentaires mais il s'avère comme
essentiel puisqu'il est prépositionnée
sur la corse
dans ce décor sauvage qui à tout instant
peut devenir hostiles l'entraînement est
capital le feu ne tolérera aucune
improvisation le beau temps c'est aussi
la sécheresse dans le cher des mesures
de restriction de prélèvement d'eau
viennent d'être décidées par la
préfecture
et puis beau temps c'est surtout la
pollution à l'ozone après un week-end
difficile dans les bouches du rhône et
dans le calvados
ce sont bordeaux et aix en provence qui
sont les plus touchés aujourd'hui mais
d'autres villes comme grenoble ou
avignon affiche celle aussi des indices
de qualité de l'air assez mauvais
grenoble qui a été survolée toute la
journée par un drôle d'avion renifleurs
les explications de dominique barrau
voici l'avion ni fleurs ni avions ni
planeur cet appareil appartenant à une
société suisse et trois jours à grenoble
pour aider à comprendre comment se forme
la pollution à l'ozone
nous travaillons sur le sujet depuis
neuf ans nous avons déjà fait des
expériences similaires dans d'autres
villes un peu partout en europe berlin
milan viennent genève et il y a une
semaine à paris fabrice l'appareil sert
notamment à déterminer l'origine des
polluants d'après les premières mesures
un quart seulement de la pollution est
d'origine grenobloise
souvent ce sont d'abord les sites péri
urbain est plutôt du sud de
l'agglomération qui on a une remontée
vers le nord à terme identifier les
zones d'origine de pollution et les
conditions de sa formation devrait
permettre de mettre en place des mesures
de lutte plus efficace et d'après la
risée sur mondiale de la santé chaque
année la pollution automobile
provoquerait la mort prématurée de 17000
personnes c'est plus que les accidents
de la route
les explications de
maisonneuve et de fred de la rue à cause
de la pollution automobile
l'hospitalisation en urgence pour
insuffisance respiratoire
le cas de ce patient à l'hôpital bichat
n'est pas isolé pour le professeur
michel aubier les populations les plus
fragiles sont les premiers à être
touchés
à l'origine le dioxyde de soufre le
dioxyde d'azoté et l'ozone les
pollutions qui augmente avec les années
déclenchant les symptômes chez tous les
malades en 20 ans disons que le nombre
d'asthmatiques dans la population
française ne peut plus et son étudiant
de 25 ans est passé de 3 % dans les
années soixante dix à 15 % maintenant en
ce qui concerne l'asthme et en ce qui
concerne la rhinite allergique une autre
manifestation inspiratoire en gros 2 5%
à 30% et ça s'observe dans tous les pays
industriels on manque d'air pur rien
qu'en france dix sept mille décès
seraient prématurées chaque année ainsi
dans le seul cas de l'ozone
nous sommes en quelque sorte des
porteurs sains un changement climatique
l'absence de vent le beau temps et une
fragilité peuvent provoquer une
insuffisance respiratoire
il va falloir quelques heures de soleil
seulement pour que l'ozone se forme et
ça c'est quelque chose de nouveau
la rapidité avec laquelle la réaction
photochimique se met en place dès qu'il
ya du soleil est un indice clair étant
permanent chargé par les précurseurs de
l'ozone pour prévenir la population des
dangers de la pollution
airparif a mis en place soixante et une
station de mesure en ile de france
leur vocation l'information au delà de
180 microgrammes par mètre cube
l'alertent au delà de 3 160 microgrammes
par mètre cube
et dans ce seul cas la circulation est
alternée
une mesure jugée bien insuffisante par
les scientifiques et les malades est
avec nous philippe douste-blazy bonsoir
donc vous êtes le le président du groupe
udf à l'assemblée ce chiffre de 17 mille
morts par an c'est ça qui vous motive
pour demander la la constitution d'une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire
oui en matière de de pollution
atmosphérique permettez modeuses de
réagir surtout comme médecin
il y a en france un million cinq cent
mille nourrissons de moins de 2 ans un
sur trois c'est-à-dire 450000 exactement
cendres atteint de bronchiolite du
nourrisson c'est à dire une sorte
d'asthme pour l'enfant pire on sait que
40 % d'entre eux sont dans les grandes
villes les agglomérations de plus de
cinq cent mille habitants dans les
petites villes 20% et il y a deux études
qu'on vient de voir dr l'instant l'une
international d'offres national qui
montrent trois chiffres terribles 17
mille décès anticipés dus à la pollution
uniquement automobile pas simplement de
moss ferrique mais aussi 258 crise de
bronchites et 188 crises d'asthme social
tout ça on le sait oui c'est un moment
déjà or le ciel c'est ce qui motive
aujourd'hui votre démarrer il faut faire
en sorte qu'ils commission d'enquêté
parlementaire qui se crée or ici la
question les chiffres accuse personne
est à l'abri de la pollution
atmosphérique tout le monde parle des
piques
aujourd'hui par exemple bien une pique
parce que il fait chaud le soleil brille
et il n'y a pas d'air pour tout le monde
s'inquiète de la pollution parce que
toulon de la ressent ce sont
essentiellement des phénomènes
inflammatoires les conjonctivites à
l'oeil les bronchites
mais entre les bic vous et moi nous ne
ressentons rien et pourtant on respire
20 kg d'air alors qu'on boit de litres
d'eau par jour
qu'est ce que vous attendez une
commission d'enquêté doit faire quoi une
eu un problème national
une prise de conscience dans le centre
du pays les médecins vient de dire la
vérité
les politiques doivent prendre leurs
responsabilités il ya d'un côté le
gouvernement de votre côté le parlement
donc j'ai demandé la création d'une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire
d'abord pour que les différents acteurs
se parle tous les partis politiques y
seront il faut pas faire de politique
politicienne avec la santé mais il y
aura les constructeurs automobiles il
faut les entendre
cependant les médecins les scientifiques
les responsables d'associations vous
avez pas les terres par ifs tout à
l'heure mais aussi et surtout l'ensemble
des maires des grandes villes de france
alors premièrement il faut mieux
surveiller pour mieux informer mieux
sensibiliser mieux protégés prévoir et
enfin et surtout il faut développer
développer des énergies propres
c'est à dire le moteur thermique le
moteur électrique les nouveaux gaz le
gpl le gaz naturel
véhicule ça c'est ça qui est très lourd
dans votre ville avec les transporteurs
mais on a un peu l'impression vous
arriver je dirais pas comme les
carabiniers mafa sur un problème qui est
traité qui est traité par le
gouvernement les verts dominique voynet
s'en occupe
relativement bien si je puis dire qu'est
ce qui fait que tout d'un coup vous avez
l'impression de reprendre deux voulaient
reprendre le dossier voulait le nom vous
réac apparaissent eux ce dossier là
c'est pas pour autant de dossiers mais
il ya urgence
quand on entend les chiffres que l'on
vient d'entendre je viens de vous donner
il y à une urgence de tous les
responsables politiques
il y aura des actions municipales je
suis sûr que il n'ya pas que le
gouvernement il ya aussi les maires qui
doivent être des acteurs de santé
publique
ils doivent partir en guerre contre la
pollution atmosphérique regardez les bus
urbains sont responsables de 70 % du
dioxyde d azote dans les grandes villes
de plus de cinq cent mille habitants
il ne faut plus de bus urbains au diesel
il faut des moteurs thermiques ou des
moteurs électriques le maire de rome
vient de faire six nouvelles lignes
électriques avec dépôt des bus de 25
classes merci beaucoup un tout petit mot
sur dominique voynet elle est agressée
hier à samedi à dole par des des hommes
qui prétendent être des chasseurs en
colère elle porte plainte et une enquête
ouverte ne trouvait que ce comportement
est est qualifiable
bon c'est affreux le toril de s'attaquer
à dominique bonnet ou à n'importe qui
comme ça la violence c'est une horreur
on est en démocratie ce n'est grande
chance et je suis bien placé pour vous
dire que on comprend pas ou quelque
chose comme ça vous arrive donc je pense
à elle je lui dis je lui dis que bon il
faut il faut prendre ça pour pour ce que
c'est c'est à dire de l'intention c'est
continuer sa route vous le meilleur tu
est victime de quelqu'un qui vous avez
agressé avec un couteau
merci beaucoup monsieur douste-blazy
d'être venu ce soir dans le journal de
france 2 à l'étranger l'actualité c'est
bien sûr le maroc au lendemain des
obsèques du roi hassan ii la vie a
repris dans le pays et chacun attend
maintenant de voir quelle sera
l'attitude de mohamed 6 la situation de
son pays est allé revente sur le plan
économique le chômage s'est accru en un
an de plus de 21% et ce sont des villes
qui vous se concentrent 80% des sans
emploi le reportage à rabat de nos
envoyés spéciaux pascal golomer et
olivier robert mises à part quelques
ouvrières occupé à faire sécher allen
tente la zone industrielle de salé près
de rabat était bien calme aujourd'hui
beaucoup avaient décidé de prolonger le
deuil une journée de plus c'est pourtant
de ses usines et des étrangers qui
investissent de l'argent que dépend une
partie de la réussite du maroc de demain
car même si en apparence les rues de
rabat respire la modernité le pays est
en retard retard économique avec une
croissance insuffisante une dette
colossale et une fonction publique
pléthorique mais retard social surtout à
cinq kilomètres à peine du centre ville
le quartier de seb
l'un de ces bidonvilles que le pouvoir
peine à faire disparaître ni eau ni
électricité
un quartier kamina aimerait quitter au
plus vite mais avec ses deux parents et
un petit métier elle décore la peau des
femmes où est née elle n'a pas les
moyens pour l'instant on voudrait avoir
une petite maison avec de l'eau nous
explique-t-elle avec un minimum
d'électricité et de quoi manger
cette vie dans ce quartier ça nous rend
malades n'est pas normal un marocain sur
deux vit avec moins de 300 francs par
mois 20 % de chômeurs c'est le dernier
chiffre officiel dont plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de diplômés
les gens ne veulent pas sortir des
villes les dom et on a besoin de
médecins dans les villages ils veulent
rester en vie les yeux restent à rabat
mais si il allait ouvrir leur cabinet
dans les douars dans les trucs et ça
leur faire du bien et y aura pas de
chômage
la fracture sociale s'est élargi pour
certains ce n'est pas la faute au
libéralisme mais est la façon dont il a
été appliqué
si la fiscalité change si un impôt sur
les fortunes ont peu équilibrée c'est
pas le libéralisme lui-même en soi qu
qui constitue un mal c'est comment tu es
qu'est libéralisme sanglant six éléments
12 il s'inscrit dans le cadre d'un état
de droit économique
je pense qu'il ne peut avoir que des
effets positifs
ce n'est donc pas seulement les
problèmes de chômage et de pauvreté que
le nouveau roi devra affronter mais tous
les blocages politiques et les
conservatismes qui depuis de nombreuses
années freine la croissance économique
du maroc dans les campagnes dans le bled
la pauvreté est également l'un des défis
à relever pour moi médecis d'autant que
la proportion de l'alphabet tête encore
plus importante philippe rochot et
philippe louzy se sont rendus à aïn
aouda un village de 2000 habitants à 50
km de rabat nous n'avons que des gouttes
ont à offrir
et heureusement pas de pétrole 10 est
ironiquement le roi hassan ii mais les
bêtes ici n'ont pas grand-chose à
brouter et la terre est sèche
le maroc est un pays essentiellement
agricole
sans les transferts de fonds et le
tourisme ils s'effondrerait les deux
mille habitants du village d'aïn el
aouda le savent et dans ses ateliers ils
ont pis les couvertures de laine
on se sent un peu orphelin le roi avait
essayé de sortir de leur enclavement ces
villages de l'intérieur c'est aussi pour
cela que les habitants ampleur et sa
loge
on trouve beaucoup de choses
l'électricité de l'eau voilà le souffle
lundi est évident maintenant parce que
le roi léa des collèges et des écoles
à l'image du maroc les deux tiers de ces
populations rurales sont analphabètes
mais le taux d'alphabétisation commence
d'augmenter surtout chez les femmes
c'était l'un des objectifs du roi hassan
2 mais l'enseignement reste très
inadaptée à la vie moderne
quand on demande à ces paysannes ce
qu'elles attendent du nouveau s'ouvre à
elle se met à pleurer sur le destin qui
leur a enlevé le roi hassan ii le roi
c'était notre amour notre père où est il
à présent ou et il nous explique qu'il a
fait beaucoup pour le pays
il était un père pour tous pour le maroc
mais aussi pour le monde et qu'il est
parti trop vite dans le village il avait
fait bâtir plusieurs immeubles populaire
mais le souci des jeunes c'était d'avoir
du travail
il ya du chômage parce que j'en ai
visité
rien que de l'agriculture donc il ya du
chômage
comme dans beaucoup de villes du maroc
c'est pourtant dans les régions rurales
comme à aïn el aouda le taux de chômage
ne dépasse pas 6% alors qu'il ya 2 1%
dans les cités comme ailleurs au maroc
le roi hassan ii a fait aussi bâtir une
mosquée pour apaiser tout mécontentement
populaire
mais cette politique n'a pas forcément
d'avenir ici les obsèques fastueuse
d'hier ont bien sûr été l'occasion de
rencontres diplomatiques imprévu c'est
ainsi que l'on a beaucoup parlé de la
rencontre entre le président algérien
bouteflika et le premier ministre
israélien ehud barak
elles ont aussi permis au nouveau roi
qui s'était jusqu'à présent surtout
distingué par ses oeuvres sociales de
faire ses premiers pas sur la scène
diplomatique maryse bloc
les funérailles du roi hassan ii
viennent à peine de s'achever
mais le nouveau souverain du maroc a dû
sécher ses larmes
il entame déjà sa vie de monarques et
les entretiens s'enchaînent abdelaziz
bouteflika président algérien
yasser arafat président de l'autorité
palestinienne ou encore ehud barak
premier ministre israélien
quand homme de 36 ans fut longtemps
tenus à distance des décisions
politiques par un père peu enclin au
partage du pouvoir
le voilà aujourd'hui face à son destin
ébranle le monde
car ce qu'il y avait hier 2 millions de
marocains sur le passage du cortège
funèbre
il y avait aussi une quarantaine de
chefs d'état et de gouvernement les
obsèques furent donc l'occasion de
rencontres spectaculaires et lourde de
symboles pour la première fois depuis le
début du processus de paix au
moyen-orient
un chef d'état algérien s'entretient
avec un premier ministre israélien
abdelaziz bouteflika interpelle ehud
barak
notre intérêt donnerait aux arabes le
même sentiment car a dit nous sommes
déterminés à renforcer la sécurité
d'israël et à mettre un terme au conflit
quelques minutes plus tard le jeune
souverain quitte le mausolée où vient
d'être enterré son père il ne s'appelle
pas encore mohamed 6 il ne portera ce
n'est qu'à l'issue de la période de
deuil de 40 jours décrétée sur tout le
royaume en attendant et dit mohamed 30
ans son talent est protégé par ses
gardes du corps
cet homme timide et introverti prend
aujourd'hui en main la destinée de 29
millions marocain et puis plus
anecdotique anecdotique on ne sait
toujours pas si le nouveau roi s'est
marié ou non certaines sources
prétendent que son mariage à lyon secret
le soir même de la mort de son père un
souverain ne pouvant régner au maroc
s'il n'est pas marié et puis d'autres
sources affirment qu'il n'en est rien
alors philippe rochot vous êtes à rabat
ce qui est sûr c'est que la marge de
manoeuvre du jeune mohamed si ce n'est
pas très importante
on l'a vu avec maryse burgot son père ne
l'ait pas vraiment préparé à ses
nouvelles fonctions
oui c'est vrai ça marche de manoeuvre
est assez limité parce que d'un côté il
a l'intention de rajeunir le
gouvernement mais de l'autre il va se
heurter a pu à la vieille garde c'est à
dire que normalement il devrait garder
comme premier ministre monsieur
youssoufi donc qui est un petit peu le
symbole de la présence de l'opposition
dans le pouvoir mais de l'autre il devra
accepter la présence et le maintien à
son pouvoir de monsieur driss basri le
ministre de l'intérieur un homme dur
c'est lui qui a préparé les funérailles
le du roi hassan 2 et c'est lui qui
tenait le
i d'une main de fer donc il pourra
difficilement se passer de cet homme
il devra aussi garder mais là c'est
plutôt une alliance qu'il formera avec
le général bennani qui commande les
troupes marocaines dans le sud du pays
où sahara donc un homme clé dans le
nouveau pouvoir
mais bien sûr le nouveau roi devra
attendre d'être intronisé officiellement
avant d'annoncer la formation de son
nouveau gouvernement
merci philippe et ce sera donc dans une
quarantaine de jours au kosovo les
obsèques des quatorze serbes tués dans
la région de graco n'ont pas pu avoir
lieu aujourd'hui les enquêteurs n'ayant
pas encore restituer les corps et bien
que les troupes de la kfor et renforcer
leur dispositif autour de la ville une
dizaine de serbes ont exigé du hcr sa
protection pour les aider à quitter la
région sur place le reportage d'agnès
vahramian et de jean françois renaud
c'est maintenant en permanence que les
militaires de la kfor stationna gras cru
des renforts pour tenter de rassurer les
serbes pour appuyer aussi le travail de
ces bérets rouges la police militaire
britannique
rien ne filtre de leurs investigations
ce matin ils ont refusé de rendre les
corps aux familles pour cause des
autopsies les villageois attendons dans
le deuil de pouvoir organiser des
funérailles
il observe sceptiques le va et vient des
caméras et des militaires enquêteurs
dans le village se faisant discret un
vice ministre serbe est venu de belgrade
sa présence nous rappelle que le kosovo
appartient toujours à la fédération
yougoslave
son message aux habitants et sans
ambiguïté nous allons faire maintenant
tout ce qui est possible pour assurer la
sécurité micro peuple faire ce qui est
nécessaire pour que cela ne recommence
jamais les britanniques ont enquêté au
tour de drakos suivant la piste d'une
vengeance albanaise dans ce village
proche
les paysans albanais ne s'aventure plus
très loin de leur maison leur version
sur les 14 meurtres penchent pour des
règlements de comptes entre serbes pro
et anti milosevic il ya un party in metz
avaient ils s'entretuent et il accuse
les allouagnais d'avoir tué les serbes
chez paul les militaires de la kfor mène
une véritable enquête criminelle
elle avec l'aide des médecins légistes
et des experts en balistique du tribunal
pénal international ils veulent aboutir
au plus vite à des arrestations et
retrouver ainsi un peu de crédibilité en
france où l'actualité c'est cet accord
intervenu entre syndicats gouvernement
patronat sur les préretraites dans
l'automobile dans l'immédiat 35 mille
salariés sont concernés dans l'ensemble
du secteur 23000 pour peugeot et renault
le gouvernement va donc aider
l'automobile française à rajeunir sa
pyramide des âges mais à certaines
conditions les explications de laurent
bailly marie richard et luc blache au
fait c'est le bout du tunnel pour les
négociations entre patrons et syndicats
de l'automobile sur la question des
traits retrait ce bail est signé par
tous les syndicats sauf la cgt cet
accord en tout cas va permettre à tous
les constructeurs de rajeunir leur
pyramide des âges 35 mille salariés sont
concernés ceux qui ont au moins 55 ans
et qui travaille tu as des postes fixes
dans des conditions usantes c'est
surtout cela qui a emporté l'adhésion
des signataires effectivement pour que
les gens d'un certain âge parce que
leurs difficultés sont supérieurs à ceux
qui sont plus jeunes et bien puisse
trouver cette solution devrait retraite
mais il s'agit bien sûr aussi de
secteurs où la pyramide des âges fait
que ces gens sont en grand nombre dans
ces secteurs le pré-retraité touchera 65
% de son salaire brut ou 50% si le
salaire en question dépasse 14 mille
francs à cas de figure plus répandue
dans la population concernée pour trois
anciens qui partiront l'employeur
n'embauchera qu'un jeune mais c'est
aussi lui qui payera le pré-retraité
jusqu'à 57 ans après l'état prendra le
relais et cet argent public pourra
représenter jusqu'à 50% du coût de la
mesure et c'est cela qui choppe la cgt
elle parle de cadeaux aux patrons
renault a annoncé 12 milliards de
bénéfices parce que quatre pour peugeot
il ya donc de l'argent pour créer des
emplois pour payer les retraites on voit
pas pourquoi aujourd'hui l'entreprise
qui montrait les financements publics
mais nous sommes que la condition
minimum 6 obtiennent un financement
public au moins saluer pour créer des
emplois ça peut pas être pour en
supprimer faire partir les anciens avec
l'aide de l'état pour embaucher des
jeunes
l'idée n'est pas nouvelle dans
l'automobile la formule retenue coûtera
moins cher à l'état que les versions
précédentes mais elle permettra aussi au
constructeur d'afficher à moindre coût
des créations d'emplois à quelques
semaines de leur passage aux 35 heures
et l'autre dossier économique du jour
c'est la guerre que se livrent toujours
élevé taux à des total on ne sait
toujours pas qui va l'emporter en
revanche cette bataille a fait des
heureux les salariés d'elf à pau puisque
la direction a préféré abandonner pour
le moment son plan de réorganisation qui
prévoyait la suppression de 1300 20
postes pour les salariés c'est la fin de
106 jours de grèves eric perrin qui sont
d'accord l'écrivain le dans le même
depuis 106 jours y voter la reconduite
de la grève aujourd'hui c'est la reprise
du travail que les salariés d'elfes et
ont unanimement choisi ambiance de fête
donc après le retrait samedi du plan
performance qui prévoyait 1320
suppressions d'emplois on peut
considérer qu'aujourd'hui c'est une
victoire totale total elf ou total nul
ne sait qui sortira vainqueur de la
bataille boursière et tout le monde a
conscience que l'eau pe qui les sauve
aujourd'hui pourrait déboucher dans le
futur sur un nouveau plan de
restructuration peut voir aujourd'hui la
détermination du personnel
c'est de se dire que demain s'il
remettait la même chose sur la table le
personnel serait motivée comme
aujourd'hui même certainement encore
plus fort donc à mon avis est un message
qu'ils doivent prendre en compte et
monsieur geoffrey et monsieur desmarest
à l'heure des bilans ce conflit reste
unique sur bien des points d'abord le
moyen utilisé voici pour la première
fois le centre informatique alpha que
les grévistes occupé quelques personnes
ont suffit pour bloquer ce lieu
stratégique avec la création d'un site
internet on a même parlé de cyber grève
l'informatique symbole de la
mondialisation de l'économie est devenu
un moyen d'action syndicale il fait une
société qui fait essentiellement des
études donc un certain nombre d'études
qui n'ont pas pu et de fait et donc on
peut estimer peut-être qu'on a perdu une
cinquantaine une centaine de millions de
francs d'études potentiel qui nous ont
échappé pendant pendant cette période la
deuxième particularité cette grève de
neuf mois n'est pas un mouvement
d'ouvriers mais de cols blancs 75 % des
employés du site sont cadres ou
techniciens supérieurs et pour beaucoup
c'était le premier vrai conflit après
avoir tenu bon 106 jours il se prépare à
faire la fête en famille en sachant que
demain tout sera peut-être à refaire
elisabeth guigou s'est rendu à la prison
des baumettes aujourd'hui l'occasion
pour la ministre de la justice de
féliciter les gardiens pour leur
comportement lors de la série
spectaculaire évasion du 26 juin dernier
l'occasion également d'annoncer un à
deux milliards de francs seraient
débloqués pour rénover cinq
établissements pénitentiaires les dom
est bien sûr mais aussi leur énergie ce
prennent la santé et nanterre aux
baumettes l'enquète sur les
circonstances de l'évasion du 26 juin
avait révélé que beaucoup de détenus
disposait en cellule de téléphones
portables leurs fournisseurs l'un des
dentistes de l'établissement a été
écroué et puis dans la sphère stranieri
les corps de frédéric adam et nathalie
girard les anciens propriétaires de la
boîte de nuit de vérifier tillon ont été
identifiés officiellement
alfredo stranieri qui avaient acheté
leur établissement a été mise en examen
pour assassinat après des années de
tergiversations et de controverses le
gouvernement renonce donc au barrage de
chambonchard sur le cher un projet
monumental estimé à 600 millions de
francs et dont edouard balladur avait
décidé la construction
cet abandon du projet c'est bien sûr une
victoire pour dominique voynet et les
verts
qu'ils étaient opposés mais c'est
surtout la fin d'un combat pour
christine jean elle avait créé le groupe
loire vivante pour s'opposer au projet
et le magazine américain time en fait
cette semaine l'une des héroïnes de la
planète louis carzou avec didier da
depuis le souvenir des brochettes péché
par son grand père j'ai préparé comme
personne par sa grand mère jusqu'aux
dernières données statistiques sur
l'état des sédiments de l'estuaire de la
loire pour christine gens c'est beaucoup
plus qu'un simple fleuve écoutez je
crois que j'ai toujours été passionné
par la nature et par l'environnement et
puis c'est vrai que
je suis au bord de la loire c'est un peu
par hasard tu commences à te sauver
steve et puis on connaît fleuve que
l'amf on se rend compte que tout au
monde du sport il ya plein de gens qui
sont amoureux ce fleuve c'est vraiment
un personnage vivant et pour la survie
de ce personnage vivant comme de ses
affluents cela fait douze ans que
christine gens parcourent grève des
rives avec la même rage de saint nazaire
jusqu'au puy en velay en passant par
chambonchard un projet de barrage sur le
cher quelques 500 hectares de vannes est
noyé au dessus de montluçon pour un coût
de 600 millions de francs
un projet sur tout dont l'état vient
finalement de décider l'abandon
une victoire de plus pour celle qui
avait déjà mené la lutte contre le
barrage de serre de la fare sur la loire
gens m'ont jamais vraiment
l'illustration de cette situation de
cette évolution c'est que plutôt que de
constituer de nouveaux stockage en eau
aujourd'hui on considère qu'il vaut
mieux utiliser les rythmes existante
d'une manière plus intelligente d'une
part et comme le barrage chambonchard
avait également un objectif
d'amélioration de la qualité de l'eau ce
qui était une aberration
enfin on a obtenu le fait que la
meilleure façon d'améliorer la qualité
de l'eau c'était bien sûr de renforcer
les moyens de dépollution
aujourd'hui christine jean est la seule
européenne est la seule femme distinguée
par le magazine américain time pour son
action en faveur de l'environnement
mais elle n'en a même pas un exemple est
sa priorité d'ailleurs mobilisés contre
les velléités d'extension du port de
saint nazaire
autrement dit encore et toujours pour la
loi
le tour de france à peine terminée les
critériums ont déjà commencé des
critériums très lucratif qui permettent
aux coureurs de rentabiliser leurs
efforts le premier d'entre eux se passe
à lisieux tout le monde s'y retrouve à
l'exception notable cette année du
maillot jaune lance armstrong dont les
prix sont décidément trop cher pour la
france quant à elle de rinxent et
jacques gerin cette année les milliers
de spectateurs présents au critérium de
lisieux ne verront pas passé le maillot
jaune du tour
24 heures après sa victoire sur les
champs elysées lance armstrong était
d'accord pour venir
mais un certain prix j'ai un manager qui
s'occupe de lance amstrong qui m'a
proposé lance armstrong pour lisieux ce
soir mais avec un cachet de 150 mille
francs nous n'avons pas les moyens
le budget de ce premier critérium situé
juste après le tour est de 450 mille
francs le succès des preuves est assurée
par la présence des coureurs du tour
cette année ils sont une vingtaine comme
françois simon inscrit à lisieux c'est
quoi le cachet d'un champion de france
en titre sur un critérium 3 je pense que
j'ai pas trop à le dévoiler
bon je suis satisfait de mon cachet mais
bon je pense que c'est personnel
ou moins qu'une victoire d'étape sur le
tour c'est moi mais tous les coureurs ne
décroche pas la timbale les affaires de
dopage ont fait baisser le prix des
cachets je serais tenté de dire que les
petits le courant baisser mais que les
gros contrats sont restés tout à fait le
contrat de richard virenque est toujours
le même depuis 1997
impossible de savoir combien touchent le
meilleur grimpeur pour venir à lisieux
de toutes les façons il fait ça par
amitié avant le tour
lisieux s'est mobilisée derrière lui ici
virenque n'a que des amis
nous partons maintenant pour avignon une
soirée exceptionnelle les organisateurs
du festival avaient demandé à jane
birkin de présenter son répertoire
habituel mais avec des partenaires de
son choix et son choix vous allez
l'entendre n'est pas du tout désagréable
bénévoles from et michel levasseur
jane birkin a choisi de participer une
soirée au festival d'avignon en
présentant une adaptation originale des
chansons de gainsbourg par un trio de
musiciens arabes algérie maroc
c'était un c'était le mélange j'espère
qu'il va porter quelque chose pour les
dessous chics par exemple c'est très
étonnant ce qu'ils ont fait ou lochrist
ration qu'ils ont fait pour
elise art
où
le groupe sert de besançon au delà de
son répertoire habituel
ces artistes tentent de saisir toutes
les variations de la musique orientale
idiot
non
il
sous d'autres mouvements
après
nos coutumes
comment fait-il
l'éclectisme est bien ce qui fait le
charme de cette soirée en plein air le
public ravi rendu hommage à ce mélange
de genres voici bientôt la fin de ce
journal je vous rappelle les principaux
titres
les alertes à la pollution se
multiplient en france après les
bouches-du-rhône et le calvados eux sont
bordeaux aix-en-provence qui connaissent
aujourd'hui une pollution à l'ozone le
beau temps et bien sûr l'absence de vent
en sont les principaux responsables
et puis au lendemain des obsèques du roi
hassan ii le maroc passe doucement dans
l'air mohamed 6 mai les défis que le
jeune roi s'apprête à relever sont
immenses entre analphabétisme et chômage
dans un instant la météo avec nathalie
rihouet suivi de jeux sans frontières le
dernier journal ce sera frairie crotta
demain 7h 50 dans les 4 vérités marie
pierre farkas recevra michel pébereau le
président de la bnp à 13h ce serait bien
sûr carole gaessler et rachid arhab et
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain soir à 20h bonne soirée
sur france 2